and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review the amazing spider-man
how many gods each the greatest movie
I've ever seen in my life
my spoilers since it's going crazy
here's this kid named Peter Parker who
looks very different from the last time
I saw him I thought she was played by
the boy who looked like Darlene from
Roseanne and he has a major problem he
was bitten by a radioactive spider I was
bitten by radioactive spider once it
turned me into a cat and she just wanted
easy radioactive spider powers but
that's the least of his problems that's
right getting radioactive spider powers
he's the least of his problems the
granted he's in high school you see it
turns out when he was a little boy his
parents just up and disappeared and his
parents were like we have to leave you
won't equal but it's okay because he
barely knows of one on scientists who
knew his father do you really want to
know what happened to your parents
are you kidding I give my right arm for
though the scientist says he'll have
them find out about his parents as long
as he helps him with his research doctor
I found the formula that can give you
your arm back oh good the only downside
is it may turn you into another to wait
and do so the scientist turns into a
giant lizard but it's okay Peter Parker
is still a giant spider and as we all
know spiders can beat a lizard any day
this doesn't bode well for you so Peter
Parker is like haha you'll never figure
out who I am now say cheese Oh property
of Peter Parker you know for a smart guy
I'm pretty stupid though spider-man goes
to his girlfriend Gwen Stacy to help him
out and she's like right I'm gonna make
an antidote right now but wait you're my
girlfriend
so within spider-man movies aren't
girlfriends just supposed to hang off of
buildings and be rescued the 1940s the
same Raimi thought - he also thought of
dancing in a bar was gonna work so Gwen
Stacy goes to meet the antidote but then
the lizard man pops in hi that's a now
grant stays here
taking this bomb and leaving bitch
so spider-man tries to stop that bomb
that's gonna turn everybody into lizards
and spider-man it's like dude why are
you trying to turn everybody into a
lizard because I've gone crazy with
power and door I have a split
personality it's not really looked into
that much it's probably the split
personality that the spider-man movies
have a fetish for that I know kind of
weird so the lizard man is stopped but
unfortunately Gwen Stacy's father is
killed and he tells Peter to always keep
his daughter out of it so Peter is like
I had to break up with you and I cannot
tell you why my father told you to do it
didn't he dude what is up with you you
like smart and contributing the
spider-man movie so are used to this
whatever are we going out or not look a
sequel to the amazing spider-man was
crazy so seriously if you really wanted
to see an actual fight between a lizard
and the spider have just come on down to
my box the winner doesn't have to be my
dinner and in this game there's only
losers this is just a reboot insane
James well at least tell me who my
shadowy guy was at the end of the movie
those guys are so silly